you probably heard that Melania Trump
had a kidney operation last month that
kind of thing happens to 48 year-olds
even famous ones she took a few weeks to
recover stayed off TV didn't give any
speeches all pretty typical for someone
who just got out of the hospital but
over its seeing that they were not
buying that story they are proud
journalists at CNN self-consciously
proud and if there's one thing they know
for certain one thing that was drummed
into them at the top shelf journalism
schools they attended it's that
Republican first lady's lie a lot and
are evil and for the sake of
civilization must be destroyed
so Siena did not buy a word of that and
the network assigned its most dogged
journalists to crack the case the
squeaky but persistent brian Stelter who
hosts some kind of weekend show that no
civilian television viewer has ever
actually seen Stelter understood
immediately that the whole kidney
operations story was just a cover for
something darker and more sinister
likely another international scandal
emanating from that Dark Lord Vladimir
Putin himself Selzer hinted as much to
his viewers watch one thing that the
president the White House have been
quite quiet about is mallya Trump and
her status the last time we caught a
glimpse of her was on Marta May 10th 24
days more than three weeks there's been
a lot of questions about her surgery her
time at Walter Reed and now her
invisibility questions about her surgery
questions about her time at Walter Reed
what questions exactly who's asking
those questions brian Stelter didn't say
because he couldn't say those are not
real questions and this is not reporting
it's a passive-aggressive attack CNN's
real point was that Melania Trump is a
liar and she's doing something immoral
she must be look who she's married to
Stephen Colbert came to the same
conclusion watch as of the time were
taping this show right now the first
lady has not been seen in public for 25
days well I'm not surprised it took that
shawshank guy years to tunnel out
Melania is supposedly reemerging to
attend an event in the White House
tonight but who can be sure because the
event will be closed to the press but
the White House did release this
official photo proving the first lady
was totally there
over at rolling stone which apparently
still exists someone called Jamil Smith
speculated that Melania Trump was in
hiding to conceal signs of physical
abuse at the Atlantic David Frum agreed
and then suggested that the president
may have punched Melania and then
ordered the Secret Service to cover it
up keep in mind that once upon a time
David Frum was a serious intellectual or
what passed for one in Washington now
he's merely a buffoon and even more
buffoonish as of last night when the
actual Melania Trump showed up at the
White House for a veteran's event very
much alive and unscathed so much for all
those questions brian Stelter pretended
to care about what's so interesting
about all this is how much journalists
hate Melania Trump imagine hating
Melania Trump whatever else she is manya
Trump is not an overbearing public
figure she's not lecturing you about
your weight they're trying to control
your personal life isn't it weighing on
I don't know tax rates or global warming
it's unlikely she will run for Senate
from New York when this is all over
nobody thinks she's one of her husband's
key political advisors you may never
even have heard Melania Trump Savoy's
many people haven't she doesn't talk
much in public Melania Trump has done
absolutely nothing wrong to you or
anyone you know or anyone you will ever
meet
she married Donald Trump that is her
only sin in the eyes of the press corps
and yet it's enough to disqualify her
even from the most basic consideration
of decency here for example is
super-sensitive modern guy comedian
Jimmy Kimmel making fun of her accent
which he thinks is silly and foreign
sounding alien really I'm curious just
like a cat ask lots of questions about
this and bad
about decent death do you think Kim
would be okay mocking the accent of one
of his mini Guatemalan housekeepers
how about of an ms-13 member please
that'd be racist but Melania
well she's Trump therefore she's guilty
there was a time when the left used to
argue that people ought to be judged for
what they do not for whom they're
related to we're all individuals
liberals were forever telling us and
thank God they were collective
punishment is wrong it is immoral that's
what they said did they ever really
believe that who knows but they
definitely don't believe it now mark
Penn was an advisor to President Clinton
Tammy bruises in New York radio show
hosts they both join us now first to you
Tammy what do you make of just to be
totally clear I'd never typically defend
the honor of politicians in fact as a
rule I don't but money Trump's not a
politician why are you attacking her
what does she have to do with it
you know in large part it's because
they're jealous and they're envious here
you've got a woman who has power she has
influence she's perfectly lovely she's
smart she speaks five languages yes she
married a man that they don't like and
but she has access now to everything
that they now do not have access to they
used to be the ones who would be fond
over who would be looked to for power
and for appointment and for for
credibility now it's a woman who never
really cares about them
has gone to certainly some cocktail
parties but it's not it doesn't care
about what the elite in Washington
necessarily thinks or or says she cares
about her son she cares about her family
she cares about her parents
and that's her crime as well but keep in
mind of course this is for every woman
who is dared to be part of this
administration and this is where when
you talk about the hypocrisy of the left
is the attacks on these women are
misogynistic and look let me say about
the attacks on on the first lady in
particular when they talk about her
either being beaten by the President or
hiding in Walter Reed or having to
secrete herself away it presumes that
she's a victim that she's helpless that
she is not willing to take care of
own life that kind of misogyny is an
insult not just to the first lady but
for women who do experience violence and
domestic violence and yet these are the
people who are supposed to be the
champions for women
the fact of the matter is is that the
arguments about championing women come
from at this point from the center-right
argument that women are individuals that
they're smart that the first lady's an
example of a powerful woman living a
life that best suits her and she should
be lauded for that well yeah I mean she
certainly ever bothered anybody mark
peten what I find so interesting about
this I'm trying to imagine the
conversation where Jeff Zucker
over at CNN calls up his sad little
errand boy that's dealt her kid and says
go ahead and tell you know it's time to
attack Melania okay then I'm thinking if
you really think that it's appealing to
attack Melania Trump of all people
Melania Trump your judgment has been
distorted well it's not politically
smart right now if you look at the last
CNN poll she was at 57 percent favorable
she had 53 percent of the women
favorable to her much higher percentage
of men because men are more Republican
but that means that you don't want to
attack Melania because you're attacking
the voters that you need and they
probably see this as a kind of wrong
idea because you know no one uses
silence better than Melania Trump and
that silence you see now has all of
America waiting to tune in tomorrow when
she reappears on the scene so
politically given her ratings it's not a
very smart thing for a column this sort
of ran the political operation at the
White House for a long time and you use
data to do it heavily use data when
people become so emotional and when a
political cause becomes a moral cause
pretty hard for them to make rational
decisions isn't it well I think that's
right I think that a lot of what we see
today is about getting back to
rationality in our politics now Hillary
Clinton as first lady endured a lot of
attacks when she went into health care
and controversial issues but when she
went to it takes a village the country
United Melania Trump is not in
controversial issues she's trying to
help kids she's doing those things that
the country can agree upon so it doesn't
make sense
guess what I dislike about this whole
thing Tammy is the way that the left has
framed everything as a moral divide so
it's like nothing about Trump can be
good and everything that is against
Trump must be good that seems like an
inherently insane way to look at the
world well it is an in and of itself
it's immoral but let me say also that
the attacks on the first lady are
personal you know we can talk about it
Hillary getting into policy that's fine
let's deal with policy issues but
remember also the attacks on the first
lady I would contend are because attacks
on the president don't work and I think
that there is an inherent decision here
a to destroy his base of support and
that is why I think she has now been
targeted clearly she's a strong woman
she knows what's going on here she's you
know the media tries to infantilized her
but she's going to stick to do with what
matters to her children's lives and
supporting her son and and her family so
this is the irony of what it is of
course that the media is doing and what
maybe even some of the establishment is
doing which is claiming that Donald
Trump is immoral and then they move and
do every single thing that they try to
project on to the president which is
that he's bad for women he treats women
badly he doesn't respect them and yet
every single thing they're doing reveals
that that I know the irony bomb has just
gone off once again mark you think you
don't think it's gonna work though as a
political matter I think this will be
over tomorrow she'll be back I I think
she has actually gotten more astute
about a handling the office of first
lady and you saw that in her rise Donald
Trump said about 40% favorable and she's
at 57 the very few people in the country
now who can break 50 were so polarized
yeah she should run from New York thank
you both Tammy mark appreciate it